[Music]
let's go to
cynthia in medford oregon hey cynthia
what's going on
hi dr john thanks for taking my call
this morning you bet how are you
i'm i'm doing pretty good um we're
blessed and
so i'm i'm grateful to be on your show
today too awesome
so anytime somebody starts something
with
i'm blessed tells me they're not doing
great but they're trying to smile their
way through something
am i on to say am i right yes sir
it's the same as when someone says hey
look at tommy over there oh bless his
heart you know something awful is about
to come about him
um so hey so what's going on
well sorry i promise i wasn't gonna cry
on here um
my husband and i have been trying to
start a family for about seven years
and i'm so sorry it's been
a rough road i have some fertility
issues
and we've done everything we can
short of you know thousands and
thousands of dollars of
procedures and things but um even then i
had
weight loss surgery um and lost 140
pounds because that was causing some of
the fertility issues
wow good for you what a stud
it's been amazing and um
oh excuse me oh you're good you're good
hey take your time go ahead
take your time we got to go ahead and
start trying again in october
and everyone said you know weight loss
will
expedite fertility my sister um had had
weight loss surgery and she
stopped at the birth control was
pregnant the next month now she's on
baby number three
um and that just hasn't happened for us
hmm normally
normally i can um deal with the anger
and heartbreak and
prayer and journaling and some hard
conversations with my husband is
absolutely amazing
um but lately that hasn't been the case
anymore
i am i teach sunday school and i work
with kids a lot
and i start crying at random times and i
have to excuse myself
when my sister told me she was pregnant
for the third time
this one was unplanned and they'll have
three under four
um and so she wasn't super excited but
um they're they're blessed
and i i left the dinner early because
i couldn't keep myself together and i
hurt her feelings that she
understands what we're going through um
but it took me a couple days to be happy
for her
sure and i i want to be happy for my
friends and my family who were
blessed this way that my normal coping
skills are just not working
yeah i'm so so sorry cynthia
no don't be sorry at all i'm sorry
you had this extraordinary picture of
what life was gonna look like
and i can tell by your the way you care
for other people
you'd be an extraordinary mother
extraordinary friend extraordinary wife
man i'm so sorry
thank you so first off you don't need to
apologize for hurting real bad
okay it feels like
after seven years and big surgery
and really going the extra mile working
really hard on your heart on
yourself and on your body and on your
marriage
and then yet you're looking at another
what almost a year
that in some ways it's the reality this
is starting to sink in on you is that
true
yeah very much so
and it's that running running running
running
running and then suddenly you can stop
and you drop your shoulders
and exhale big and go oh my gosh is this
my life
i think it's starting to hit that this
this might not happen for us um
i've been able to just say well don't
try again next month or
it'll happen eventually and i know i'm
not super old
i'm 34 so it could still happen but oh
you're a baby
but listen but listen listen
this is the worst and there's something
really important about
dropping your shoulders just sitting in
it for a minute you've been sprinting
for seven years
really hard
and it's just tiring and exhausting and
frustrating
and you probably have a room picked out
in your house that you walk by and it's
still empty
is that right yep
and dude if another person
instagrams oh my gosh number four right
yes yeah i have a sister and a
sister-in-law
that um are both unexpectedly pregnant
one at 40
and one you just had you know two in two
years and
it's just sure man why not hey while
we're laying down how about everybody i
know and love
just come over and kick me that'd be fun
that's that's kind of how it feels and i
know that that's not that's not what
they plan and i i just want to be happy
for them but
some days it's real rough yeah so
grief um grief's like sitting on a raft
in the ocean
right and sometimes it is so still
and peaceful and you see the sun coming
up and birds are flying overhead and
it's just
simply this awe-inspiring moment
and sometimes grief is a giant way that
knocks you over
and then you get sucked under by the
undertone you don't know if you're gonna
be able to come back out and because you
can't breathe
right and it never kills you but man it
feels like it's about to
and then all of a sudden you look up and
two people that you do care about you do
love and you do
you are genuinely excited for them right
they've
got tears in their eyes because suddenly
it's a whole thing now and all that so
a couple of thoughts here i've lived
this
okay on my side of it i i can never
speak to what someone who wants to be a
mom feels like
um but man i've
sat there and watched a hurt that i i
didn't have words for
and i felt that man that empty that long
walk down the hallway i know that room's
empty down there i just see i know it is
and um
so here's a couple of things number one
your grief is your grief is your grief
and if you haven't already i think it's
time for a conversation no you know what
you probably have so tell me about this
what is the conversation been like when
you sit down with your husband whether
y'all are on a date y'all are just
laying there in the middle of the night
and you can't sleep
and y'all have the what do we do if this
doesn't work conversation
what's that been like
um it's a little complicated um
i've always thought of adoption would be
a great way i
i know i have a lot of love in my heart
and it doesn't have to be my kid
necessarily
um but my husband had a really rough
childhood and
he's a felon um
the lord saved him probably i think 11
or 12 years ago so
he is the most wonderful man um but
that by itself would cause us a
really big struggle um i'm not sure if
that is something that that would
completely keep us from adopting but i
think it might
um and
i i i feel some guilt that this is my
fault
and hold on the idea of putting him
through that struggle and being told no
because of
him i know but listen i'm gonna ask you
not to do that to yourself
okay this is a heartbreak situation not
a my fault situation
okay i know he says the same thing he's
been so supportive and loving it's
it's annoying and frustrating at how
supportive he's being i know
you just want him to be pissed off and
angry and smashed up so you can both
hate and be mad and angry together
and that's not the guy you married he's
a good guy and so just some strange
random dude on the other side of the
country i'm telling you
your feelings are valuable right they
they have value to them they're legit
the feeling of anger super real
and honest the feeling of
being um raged out that everyone around
you is having kids it feels like they're
not but it feels that way
legit the
the the feeling of guilt that this is
your fault
it's a real feeling but it's not true
okay okay it's not true
and one important thing that i always
ask folks to do is get all those
feelings out on the table and then just
mine them for evidence
just demand evidence from them is that a
true statement feel them
accept them but then be able to sit down
and say is this one true
and you can get all into the mechanics
at all into the weeds and only if only
and then you're gonna look at your
husband and say what i'm denying him
this
man here's the thing that is a futile
road to travel okay
there is nothing that comes of that road
at all
except ash okay um
he is probably grieving too and so
here's a couple things i want you to do
i'll circle back
number one i want you all to have a
planned conversation
a planned real truthful conversation
that's on the calendar that you both
know is coming
that's going to be about what if
what are we actually going to do if we
look up and a year from now
um we're not pregnant
i want you to get some real data about
the
adoption process what does that actually
look like because right now it's just a
pipe dream it's just a
i think it's going to be really hard or
it's not going to be really hard it's
going to be really expensive i'll
get some actual true firm data and
even before that ask him if he actually
wants to adopt
right is that something a journey he
wants to go down to
and you're gonna find some some
differences some assurances some
i don't know all that kind of stuff is
going to come out there too
but make sure you're on the same page
and then the third thing is give each
other space to grieve this thing
and grief's going to look different for
everybody
for you it may be don't work with kids
for a season
right when i was working crisis um
and i had a little baby seven or eight
month old daughter
i wouldn't work child cases i just
wouldn't do it i couldn't
and then still be well and still be
whole and be able to work that scene
appropriately and go home and be present
with my daughter appropriately i
couldn't do it
and so i had to opt out of small infant
child cases
and it was just for a season now i can
my kid's older
but i probably wouldn't show up to a six
or seven or eight year old right now
because i got a six and seven eight year
old right right and so
it may be a season that you put some
space between you and ba within
and working with little babies with
little kids give yourself an opportunity
to heal
okay and not heal like it's not gonna
hurt not like that
but heal so that you can breathe
normally
that you can rediscover the joy in kids
and not that
pain right not that mirror walking up to
what you don't have
and if you can't make it to a an event
and a dinner you don't know anybody an
explanation
you owe them a hey we can't make it
tonight we'll be there next time
right or we'll do our best to be there
you don't need to put an excuse you
don't need
nothing and you don't have to i mean you
don't have to apologize you can just
totally own that thing
right you can just own it why because
it's your life and it's your boundaries
and it's your relationship and it's your
husband and y'all go to cracker barrel
in the middle of night if that's what
you want to do you'll get diabetes and
that probably wouldn't be good but
um you can go eat wherever you want to
go you can go do what you want to do
right you don't owe anybody explanations
for things
you can get off instagram you can get
off facebook you don't have to see
every birth announcement show up to
every uh what do they call them the
when they poof like pink and blue
powder into the gender reveal yeah
whatever those things are you don't do
any of that crap
you have to do any of it right but that
comes from
healing that comes from grieving deeply
that comes from acknowledging the
reality of where we are
seven hard hard years
just sitting in that for a bit feeling
it
riding those waves and they're big and
messy and heavy
and so annoying and they come out of the
blue and they drag us underwater but
they don't kill us they never do
then we pop back out and then you see
that former felon turned incredible
husband's arm reaching down to pull you
out of the water and sometimes you're
gonna pull him out
and then you're gonna own what tomorrow
looks like you're gonna figure it out
but you can only do that if you are
grieving together letting each other
grieve
whatever hey he may grieve by just being
a weirdo and wanting to get video games
don't let him do that by the way but
everybody grieves different
and he may grieve by reading dumb
science articles and he may grieve by
feeling the blank feeling y'all both
going to do it differently be so
graceful with each other
so graceful and then yeah own what
tomorrow looks like
write that new narrative and figure it
out if that's adoption if that's
fostering if that
is being the greatest aunt and uncle of
all time
if that is being a full-time rando
babysitter for folks who can't afford
babysitting in your local community
whatever that looks like for you
own it rock it deal with those ups and
downs when you get frustrated and sad
you will grieve this for the rest of
your life
it'll be something right it'll be hard
and painful and
there's beauty and joy on the other side
of this
you just gotta ride out those storms
i'm so so sorry but i'm so grateful how
brave you are
i'm so grateful your husband loves you
i'm grateful you love him and i'm
grateful for your heart and
person you are in your local community
and they're lucky to have you
at the end today so so sorry that you're
going through this
man we love you
keep us posted on what comes next let us
know how that grieving conversation goes
and that
acknowledging conversation goes and
we'll be thinking about you